hi guys i'm aaron ruck and i'm pretty
excited today because we'll be doing a
setup on our haas st20y so what we're
going to do is we're going to take this
raw piece of material we got right here
and we're going to be transforming it
into this part in one operation that's
right we're going to be doing a transfer
using a dual spindle machine
so the tools i'll be using to make this
part i've got some sandvik cnmg 432s and
i've got a sandvik dnmg 431 for doing my
turning and my facing i've also got
an escar
tang grip grooving tool and that really
helps give me that extra reach that i
need for those deeper grooves and i'm
also going to be making my hole with a
mitsubishi one-inch insert drill and
then i'll be topping it all off with
another kin of metal three-quarter
boring bar ccmt
and i'm gonna have a one on that tool
nose radius all right so let's go ahead
and dive into it and let's get this set
up going
so if you'll notice i have all my tools
already loaded onto my turret and i also
have my jaws that i made for this job
already mounted onto my chuck and i have
the sub spindle as well
it is very important that when you make
your jaws for your machines that you
stamp them one two or three and load
them in the same location when you put
them back on the same machine that will
really help out with your run out
however
when you do put your material into your
jaws you will notice that it will look
like it has a little bit of run out that
is because the material is not perfectly
round we have not cut it yet so it's not
a machine surface so this is about the
amount of wobble that you will see
on the part when it is in the chuck jaws
before you start
so the first thing i want to do after
i've honed out my machine is i want to
load the program i'm going to be using
into the memory so i have my program on
my usb
and i will be going into list program
and then from here you'll see that i
have my tabs at the top
so on memory i don't have my program in
there so if i go to usb
i'm going to be loading this program
right here at the bottom so i will hit
enter to select the program i want to be
using
then i will hit f2 okay now there is a
way to hit load selected program but it
will load it with the usb being the
current selected command so it's going
to try and run the program out of the
usb
so i'm going to go into memory
and then i'm going to hit enter one more
time
and then i might say there's already
something in there i do want to override
it
i like that right there so it looks
really good
so
i can see down here if i go into edit
but i have all these tools
right here i have my cnmg i have my my
grooving tool i have my insert drill i
have my boring bar i have a just a
regular dropper drill and then i also
have for the back side of the turret
when i do my op 2 i have a dnmg and i
have another boring bar
so if you'll notice here we have our
g10s so what our g10s do is if i have a
very
labor-intensive setup where it's taking
a lot of time and i have to
break down that setup and come back to
it again later by having these g10s and
using the same tools and using those
same jaws that actually reduces the
setup time substantially because i
already know all of these work offsets
are very close to what we need to do so
what i got to do now is i got to touch
off all these tools off my tool eye so
let's get started on that
okay so
i've already identified my tools i'm
going to be using so i want to first
call up the first tool i'm going to be
setting so i want to set tool number one
so i'm going to go into mdi
and i can do it two ways i can hit
t101 into block insert cycle start or
i can simply go to t1 which will go to
turret one position and i can hit turret
forward
so my machine came on if i already have
turret one in location it will not
rotate so if i wanted to know what tool
was in that position i can come up here
and i can see that tool one
is active in the carousel also if i come
to my offsets you can also see the
active tool is tool one that is in the
spindle location
so i need to be in edit
to start setting the tools so let's come
up here
to our probing system i'm going to come
down
i'm going to go over for probing i want
to set tool offsets and i want to do
turning tools because this is a turning
tool okay
i'm going to start off with a manual
because i don't have anything set so
automatic is not it's kind of shooting
in the dark is what it's going to be
doing so i want to go to manual
and you'll see that the first thing it
wants me to do is hit f2 so if you look
right here
when i hit f2
it will bring up another page and it
says that the status is that it is
retracted so i want to bring it down so
i'm going to hit f2 again
and now my tool eye is in a good
location so now that i have my tool
light down i'm simply going to hit undo
because i don't need to be in this
screen anymore
so when i come out of the screen i'm
literally just going to go
down
and it's going to explain to me what's
going on so because tool 1 is the active
tool
it auto defaults to one now offset
because i am using this offset t101
which is in my program i'm gonna set my
offsets to one i also have a turret
location one but i'll be using offset 24
and if i was doing that i would simply
type in 24 and i'll show you that as
well so let's change this back to a one
tool tip direction very cool gives you
an idea of what direction i am in for my
tool tip direction so i am doing outside
facing so i will be doing tool tip
direction three
and i'll hit enter
so once this is all done you'll notice
that it popped up some information right
here below
if i cursor down
this controller will actually tell me
what direction and what side of the tool
i want to be on so if you look down here
you're going to press hand jog and then
the axis and then you're going to jog
the tool
close to this location which is 250
thousandths or 6 millimeters of the
probe so let's go in the hand jog
and let's open our door
so if i look right here we're going to
go ahead and handle down
to our tool
now i'm going pretty fast
make sure you all take your time
that right there looks pretty good so
i'm going to go ahead and i'm going to
hit cycle start after i close my door
before we hit cycle start i want to make
sure i am in edit
and it says to run an mdi so now i'll
hit cycle start and we'll watch it set
its offsets
and just like that
i have set the tool length in the z and
x axis for this tool didn't take very
long at all so what i want to do now is
i'm going to handle away
from my tool probe
and once i get a little bit far away
from it i want to go ahead and put it up
so i'll close my door
again i'll go back into edit
and then i'm going to hit f2
it's extended make sure you are not
going to hit my probe
and then you're going to retract it so
now it is retracted so from here i will
hit undo to exit i'm going to hit power
up restart and i'm going to hit the
letter a
i'm going to be hitting that quite a bit
because what that does is that puts me
in a safe location so i know i can index
the turret without the the fear of
hitting anything so the next tool i want
to do is tool three so mdi
let's hit a race program i'm going to
hit t3
turn forward
and now i will go back to edit
if you'll notice it kept me right here
and i'm just going to follow the same
process i'm going to hit f2 twice
wants to activate my screen
two to bring it down
and then i'm going to hit undo
and if i cursor down you'll notice that
it already went to the active tool
current tool number
and then when i go down
it wants to put in offset one but i
don't want it an offset one i want to
put it in offset three so i change it
there
tool tip direction will remain the same
because it is my grooving tool so i will
be on the outside
so i'll leave it as a three
and it's going to give me the same
instructions so let's go ahead and go to
jog i'll open up my door
and then we will handle towards that
same location
again take your time on this it's not a
race
we're going to make sure all tools that
we set are correct and then i will close
my door
i will hit edit
and then i'll hit cycle start
and notice that it's taking two hits on
here
that's to ensure the initial hit and
then the second hit is for accuracy
so again i'll go into jog i will handle
away in the positive axis
i will close my door
i'll hit edit
f2 i want to put my tool light back
and then i will hit undo power up a
so again i'm just going to repeat this
process until all my tools are touched
so i will show you how to do
our insert drill our boring bar and our
drill so let's keep on going so let's go
to mdi
erase program i'm gonna hit t8 turn
forward
and then we'll go to edit
f2
i'll hit undo
now this one will be a little bit
different
i'm going to set my 8 to my offsets but
my tool tip direction is just going to
be seven
so i want to make sure when i bring my
tool down that it is right in front of
the tool eye because if i cursor down
one more time
you'll notice that it wants me to be
again
250 thousandths in front of the tool eye
so let's go
hand jog z
all right so let's open up our door and
let's set our drill
so i'm going to hand jog i'm in the z
i'm going to come over and i'm going to
come down
and i want to make sure my insert is
what's touching the tool eye when it
gets to it
now i'm going to close my door
i'm going to go into edit
and i'm going to hit cycle start
[Music]
now something to remember on this is it
only set the z-axis so what does that
mean that means i haven't set my x-axis
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go into offsets
this is tool a it is in the spindle or
the turret is active so if i activate or
highlight
the the x geometry you'll notice i have
some additional codes down here well
this is a bolt-on tool so it's going to
set the center line if i push
f3 now that is a setting in the machine
that knows where the center line is with
the bolt-on tool so very cool very quick
all of my drills will be set just like
that so again let's handle away
from my tool eye
then we'll close our door
i'm going to go back to edit i'm going
to hit f2
and put my tool i up
i'll hit undo i want to power up and
home and hit a
so we're going to keep on going next
thing i have
is our boring bar so it's gonna be tool
number six so let's go mdi
erase program t6
turret forward
so now
i'm going to go ahead and go back to
edit
i'm going to come up to the top we'll
hit f2 let's get that retracted
now it's extended
so i'll hit undo
tool six is active let's change that to
six
and i'm going to come down here now
notice i got another tooltip direction
change it's going to be
the two because we are doing id boring
so i'm going to change that to two and
now when i come down to my cursor notice
it tells me i want to be in that area
right there
all right so let's go to let's
open up our door
let's go on our z-axis
and let's handle it to that location
so again i want to make sure i'm not
hitting anything on the back side of my
spindle whenever i get here
now that looks pretty good i'm going to
go ahead and close my door
hit edit and then i'm going to hit cycle
start
[Music]
very good so now that i've set that tool
right there i'm almost done so i'm going
to go in the handle
make sure i move the right direction
close my door
you don't want to go too far because you
have a boring bar on the other side i'm
going to hit power up and the letter a
i'll come back to edit
hit f2
let's retract our tool eye and i'm
retracting my tool light every time i
index my turret before i index my turret
it is a good habit
so exit i'm ready to set my next tool
which is going to be again a drill so
i'm only going to set that one direction
right there so let's go to mdi erase
program
t11
and then we'll hit turret forward
next thing i want to do
so i'm going to go back to edit
hit f2 so that we can extend our tool
eye
now hit undo i know this is a bit
repetitive but it's very good that you
get this into a rhythm and slash routine
so tool 11 is there
so 11 from my work offsets
seven
for that right there
and then i just need to position it
right where i want to go so now let's
open our door and go on hand
jog and let's put this
250 thousandths in front of my tool eye
all right very good so let's close our
door
we're going to edit and i'll simply hit
cycle start
[Music]
before i do anything else because this
is a drill and it's on center
i want to come right here and i want to
hit
set to bot center line bolt-on tool
f3 you'll notice they are both the same
makes it very easy all right so let's go
in the handle let's move away from my
tool eye go the right direction
close our door
go to edit and hit f2 twice
let's put that tool i up
then i'll hit undo so if you'll notice
let's go back to edit
memory i have set all the tools for the
front side of my part
now i have to set some tools on the back
side of my tool eye now this is going to
be a little bit tricky because i can't
physically touch the boring bar to the
tool eye so we're going to set that a
little bit differently but for the x
i'll teach you a quick trick on what has
worked for me
but before i teach you that let's go
ahead and set the dnmg
431 but first i got to make sure that i
send it home so i want to go to power up
hit the letter a
so i want to go to mdi
i'll erase my program
and remember it is still turret one
location
but it's gonna be offset 21. so i'll hit
turret forward
now that i'm at that location i'll go
back to my edit
i'll hit f2
hit it twice to retract
and then i'm going to go ahead and i'm
going to hit undo and we'll get this
ready so notice it says 11. this is
where i'm going to set
21. now this depends on whatever you
have it called as in your program so in
my program it says t1
21 all in the same line
so now i'm going to come down here
tooltip direction is going to be a 4
because we are going to be cutting on
the sub spindle outside
so i'm going to hit a 4
input and then when i arrow down
it will tell me which side it needs to
be on
so let's go ahead and open up our door
go into hand jog
and let's go ahead and position ourself
in the right location now this is why we
don't have a material in the jaws
so that we don't run into it
now that i am pretty close to where i
want to be at
i will come back to edit
i'll close my door
and i will simply hit cycle start
very good so now i have set all of my
tools with the tool eye so the first
thing i want to do is i want to
carefully
handle up an x
and i want to handle carefully away from
the tool eye
and then i will put the tool eye up
knowing that when it goes up it will not
hit anything so i'll go back to edit
hit f2
and i will retract
the tool eye so now i will hit undo
power up
hit the letter a
so it puts my machine back to a safe
position
now here's my trick i was telling you
about
i go to my offsets tool number six
and tools 624
are both on the same
tool holder therefore i'm going to make
my x the same
for both of these because they are the
same size boring bars
so i'll simply type in minus 15 inches
thousands of four tenths
and i will find
position 24
and i will hit enter
i will hit yes because i do want to put
that in there i'm ready to go so here's
two ways i can set the z i can run this
whole part and whenever it gets done
running before it runs this tool in the
program
i can bring my tool
to the face of the part
and touch off and i can hit z face
measure however i want to do this
right now because i have a finished part
with me so here's what i got to remember
my g10s right here
i'll be using
g56
whenever i get down there to use that
one boring bar okay if you'll notice b
minus three inches that means my b or my
sub spindle is going to
come
away from its home location by three
inches
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
first call up the tool that i want to
set
mdi
erase program
index turret
okay so now pay attention i'm going to
go g
o
g 56
b minus three inches
in the block insert now what that's
going to do is it's going to move my
machine into the machining location that
sub spindle it'll put it in the location
where the machining will be done the
reason why i'm doing that is because z0
is the face of my part so if i don't
have my tool eye
this is how i would have to touch off
all my tools on both spindles so i'm
going to hit cycle start
you'll see that it did move up
three inches now that it is in the
location where it's going to be machined
i'm going to come over here and i'm
going to
set my tool link so it's going to handle
let's open up our door
and we're going to move it into location
remember i'm taking my time i'm not
going too fast
and then when i'm close i reduce those
increments so as you can see i'm coming
pretty close
so i want to grab my piece of paper and
i'm going to start coming in here in
very slow increments
until my paper stops moving
once my paper does stop moving
i'm going to come back to my offsets
page and i'm going to come to my cursor
right here and i'm going to put it on
the z geometry and again i will push
z face measure so that's going to be a
negative six inches
nine hundred and thirty eight thousand
so that's how far the tool is from the
home position
to the face of that part okay so now
what i need to do is i need to go in the
handle
make sure i come off the face of the
part
going to close my door
and then i will go to power up
letter a
and that's going to send all my accesses
home safely
so here's the good news
i've got all my tool lengths set
all my work offsets are going to be set
with my g10
and i have all the jaws that i used from
the last time i ran this job already
mounted and ready to go that means by
just saving those jaws and identifying
them with the machine they go on and
reloading them in the correct location i
have saved a ton of time setting up this
job so my graphics looked good i'm ready
to run and if you click on the link in
the description below you can actually
see this part
run from cycle start to finish including
the part transfer so again i'm aaron
runk and i really hope you enjoyed this
setup video as much as i did and i hope
it helps you in your setups helps you
with some cool tricks and get you going
forward good luck out there thank you